I wish I could fly
like apply everything when you like
[Music]
my name is uh Clinton Brown third I am
34 years old I'm from Long Island New
York
and I happen to be a little person how
do I feel like society views little
people with discontent with this candid
a lot the word [ __ ] send shivers down
my spine it's like well you're an object
you're not human society teaches a
certain perspective but it doesn't teach
the little person
it's going to the Super Bowl
the world is built for tall people I
think it's up to the little person to
carve their own way
Clinton got the deluxe package he had
club feet dislocated hips dislocated
knees he had severe scoliosis and
kyphosis goalie osis is the S of the
spine that the kaitos is the bowing of
the spine
I've had 30 showed you 30 at the end of
the day bill it's made me the strong
person that I am I work in finance for a
cable television company I think
naturally habitually I've always been
somebody who wanted to get up go and
tackle the world you know make an
impression whether on this high or 6
foot 10
[Music]
about six years ago they started
little-person basketball team
hey guys Justin Tompkins as always been
blinding on Gordon
[Music]
katoya was always a defensive specialist
Khan has become the cabinet
Danny was always the globe how they came
together
John's quick and he's a sharpshooter
[Music]
blazes the power forward and shoot the
mid-range
tell you was the baby at first and now
he's a joker not only is Jackson thinkin
but Jackie where everybody else was I've
always been the architect every
personality and every person they could
the NHS becomes fine all right 20 2016
2006
and we're gonna prepare like we've
always prepared individuals practicing
on your own because we don't see judge
much during the year I think just in
time is 23 years old living room Upper
West Side Douglass projects I always
played my hardest I always feel like I
have to prove something the towers gave
me a lot more confident every since that
first convention scene the little people
like interacting playing basketball I
thought wow anybody could do anything
that they want there's no guys they keep
trying the LPA convention it's kind of
like a spring break because it's the
time that you get to spend with people
who are really judging you for how you
look you're not the different person you
blend in with the crowd it brings a lot
of character right over the yeah let's
get over and hop on that roof and then
hop over and I'm down there do that
you see a soccer ball yeah Horton's in
your back neighbor's yard at the same
time that the towers became a family I
met my special wife and at that point in
time in my life I didn't know if I was
ever going to find a significant honor
and when I met Sophia
there was no other questions I couldn't
ask for anything more
our first official date Clinton showed
up to my house in a full suit with a one
rose on Valentine's Day and took me to
dinner
that set the stage for the last six
years I would love to have a family I
would love to have a family I will be
honest and say that I am very very
scared to be pregnant I don't know what
that means really for me there can be a
lot of complications with stuff like
especially if you're a little person but
like when we get there we'll figure it
out but I think that we're both excited
to maybe start that for us yeah I think
we're also open for adoption - oh yeah
definitely dot they probably I mean
specifically a little person definitely
not a person in from a country that
shunned them and yeah to let them grow
up in a warm household I think that
would be special to us I think that
would be so special
yeah yeah so that is something else that
I think I look over - yeah we'll see
where the chips fall right yeah how many
of them Falls Oh God
there's a little person in high school
you are out of ten things because you
physically can't compete in sports I
think the future of the towers can be a
real warm up defense in football you got
this the safety drops back and he's got
this whole area that he has to cover
same thing with basketball we've got on
younger guys younger athletes to see
that the role model of the older guy and
show them that there's a path
I love that I come out to my clothes
folded and my coaching outfit I got a
made it I got it absolutely made thanks
bear dad yeah I'm a lucky man better and
he I bring bear your MA blue pants this
is what I call you Bob blue pants give
me a like a hiragana neither the softest
brizi isn't bad boys ever they go on
every trip the babalu pens go on every
trip this you pair this with a nice Airy
button-down you got yourself a beautiful
outfit I'm making a mess somewhere all
over the world and country those people
just like me getting excited packing
like it's the best pack they've ever
packed you know what I'm saying it's
pretty name last year was the first year
the towers ever swept all sports we won
every team sport last year now I would
like to do the same I sometimes my goals
are a little lofty but if you don't
shoot for the sky you're never gonna get
it put your foot on the pedal and you
guess it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think an important and it's fun to be
around people who are like you or
physically like you and that are going
through the same thing that you are in
your life you know it's great to see
that I think it all sports we're gonna
come out guns blazing and I'll be damned
if we come away with anything less than
we deserve
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
towers are the champions last five years
but you can never underestimate anything
[Music]
we're trying to take your crown Oh China
you know if you thrown the bill dose for
this one week is just tremendous
you're really gonna make your mark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know where the three famous
all right throw that back coming home
has you know a bit of depression to it a
couple of weeks in a couple of months
that'll all go away and you know you'll
look forward to the next gathering
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]